we start on the west coast
that's in california which is seeing
some of its worst weather in years
forecasters call it a bomb cyclone that
has already blasted the pacific
northwest killing two people in northern
california some streets are underwater
or covered by mudslides in areas burned
by the summer wildfires radar shows how
much rain there is up to 10 inches
falling in just 24 hours our lead
national correspondent david begno is in
carmichael california just east of
sacramento david good morning
good morning to you what we're seeing
right now is water receding pretty
rapidly that's the good news no major
damage to property or people but let me
tell you this storm has lived up to
everything they said it would be in
terms of rainfall and how much they get
this sacramento area hadn't had rain in
more than 200 days they just set an
all-time record
it has been a monster storm uprooting
trees flooding rivers in northern
california and turning creeks into mud
filled rivers
in san rafael just north of san
francisco there were more than 300 calls
for help from fire or police that's four
times what it is normally
across the region officials say they may
not know the full extent of the damage
in those burned areas until later today
with the rains and winds coming through
it's kind of it's
anyone's guess on what's going to occur
now look at this that big truck was
almost pushed over by strong winds on a
bridge just north of san francisco and
on the world famous golden gate bridge
gale force winds actually caused
vibrations that created this eerie
whistle that you could apparently hear
from miles listen
farther inland a substantial landslide
shut down this major highway in the same
area as this summer's massive dixie fire
that happened just north of sacramento
closer to sacramento in the town of
carmichael there were roads underwater
as of late sunday more than five inches
of rain fell in california state capitol
breaking the previous record that was
set back in 1880
meanwhile up in washington state this
road east of seattle was closed after a
tree fell and crushed a vehicle killing
two people
all i could think about right now are
their families something like so random
is just
awful so the rain will stop here shortly
southern california will feel the
impacts later today but the rain will be
much less in terms of the amounts
falling down there just to give you an
idea for context rain is such a big deal
here because they get it so little i
remember i was a local news reporter
here my very first day on the job they
said you're going to cover the rain and
i said the rain you actually cover the
rain here we cover rain in louisiana
where i'm from when you get a hurricane
and they said oh no when it rains here
it's a big story so you can imagine when
you get a rain that sets a record it's
not only a big story but folks here are
very happy to see it
no it's huge david 200 days without rain
and then a record-setting day uh thank
you very much stay dry if you can sounds
like you will be able to